la visiteuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus attendre
non
[Musique]
je suis prof dans un lycée parisien du
3e arrondissement
je suis venu là dans le cadre de
l'interpro qui s'est mise en place
un peu par rapport au niveau de paris et
qui fait que les différents secteurs en
lutte qui sont de plus en plus nombreux
se réunissent et se soutiennent les uns
les autres se renforce et donc à essence
et c'est pour ça que je suis là dans les
lycées la grogne de plus en plus
importante
elle monte avec des actions qui sont pas
forcément médiatisé et qui sont très
nombreuses en termes de blocage des
lycées parlée par les élèves eux-mêmes
les blocages des collèges par des
parents d'élèves nombreux et puis
également des grèves qui se qui se
multiplient des grèves des reproductions
au niveau des établissements parisiens
notamment des plus prestigieux henri iv
louis legrand notamment donc c'est
quelque chose de fort qui se met en
place qui se développe et qui vient à
point nommé au moment où ça commence à
devenir dur pour nos camarades
de cheminots et de la ratp donc voilà la
lutte n'est pas finie
hier le cortège de la manifestation à la
sur paris était était fort et le cortège
des pardons des profs était un des plus
importants qu'on ait eu depuis le début
du mouvement
donc à ce qu'ils pensent et à ceux qui
veulent nous faire croire que la
mobilisation est en train de décliner
non ce n'est pas le cas et aujourd'hui
c'est c'est hautement symbolique ce lieu
ce lieu de culture qui qui doit rester
déjà un lieu de culture et pas un lieu
un lieu d'argent a lieu où enfin bref le
fait que ce soit des travailleurs qui
défendent ce lieu de culture moi je
trouve ça admirable je suis prof mais on
est loin d'être que des proches et du
personnel de la culture il ya des gens
d'un peu tous les secteurs et c'est ça
qui est fort et c'est ça qui nous nous
laisse un espoir que contourne comment
défendre la culture
je suis parti à 7 heures du matin dijon
chez moi pour une oeuvre à l'exploit
l'expo l'honneur d'avancé mais pas très
grave
ce que s'ils font pas grève y aura plus
vraiment de louvre comme on connaît ça
donc moi ça me dérange pas voilà je suis
plutôt contente je les soutiens je reste
là bas ce que les obus sont rigolos et
je vais voir si un peu mais sinon c'est
pas grave je verrai faire un tour
ailleurs mon sentiment je moi je viens
de bourgogne junte auxerre 6 pour
répondre dans le cadre de témoignages
précédents
la jeune femme qui avait tout à fait le
droit d'ailleurs mais qui donc soutenait
bien qu'elles viennent de loin et qu
elle pas pu voir son expo mois celle
inverse
moi je viens de loin j'ai eu du mal à
prendre un trajet du malade du 30
derniers jours ici je peux avoir mon
berceau tir au ras et je peux vous dire
que tous les gens qu'on a vu ce matin la
presse pedro monde mais les gens sont
contre les gens ne sont pas contents
sauf qu'on ne dit rien et c'est bien
dommage on est contre il ne devrait pas
être là faire une heure de piquets de
grève grève
ok pour manifester leur avis très bien
emmerdé excusez moi le mot toute la
journée les gens qui viennent visiter
qui viennent de loin ça c'est honteux et
nous il nous brise notre liberté ils
parlent de leur liberté mais il pense
pas à la nôtre voilà un on connaît
l'adage la liberté des uns s'arrête là
où commence celle des autres
voilà merci pourquoi vous ne dégagez pas
dégagé et nous on est qu'il a germé chez
d'accord avec vous c'est pas ça c'est
pas la peine d'essayer la tradition veut
dire le mot à dégager ça non
mais si rappelez vous on pas se laisser
faire par une poignée qui nous empêche
de vivre
pourquoi on reste toujours faire
pourquoi on se laisse toujours faire
bien le même nombre de dents a forcé le
barrage
si quelqu'un veut bien me prêter ma
forte je suis prête à forcer le barrage
parce que c'est aussi cette situation
est inadmissible moi j'ai rien à faire
avec un problème de retraite
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mm
il y en aura
[Applaudissements]
warhammer